with the midterm election coming up CBS
News is bringing back its Battleground
tracker studying all 435 races for the
House of Representatives CBS News
elections and surveys directed that's
Anthony salvanto he is here for a closer
look at the numbers good to see you man
great to see you bud all right so let's
talk the house uh what could cause the
Democrats to lose their majority okay so
but let's start with this the current
house blue for Democratic seats read for
republicans and what folks should see is
Democrats have this narrow majority just
over that 218 line that you need well we
talked to voters in all these districts
and when you put that together in the
model right now I'm going to show you
how this just swings a little bit you
see some of these seats go over the line
that would give the Republicans control
at 230 currently where things stand now
the reason for that number one reason
I'm going to show you is voters say
what's on their mind is the way they
think things are just going in the
country and they think it's going badly
so what happens well they start to
punish the honey the party in power for
that and those who think it's going
badly are breaking towards the
Republicans all right so it's not a red
wave but a win is still a win let's talk
about some of the issues that could
drive voters to the polls Roe versus
Wade the January 6 hearings could that
help the Democrats okay let's start with
Rogue versus Wade I looked in particular
at women under 50 because they're such
an important part of the Democrats base
well for them they're saying the
abortion issue is just as important as
the economy and the inflation and
inflation now look at what's going on
with women registered voters generally
they think that a republican majority
would make things in the country worse
for women more so than better all of
this affects the Democratic base because
Democrats need these votes well what
happens Vlad you look at the Democratic
base saying that their party is not
doing enough to protect abortion access
so Democrats still need to fire up that
base and say they can do something about
that issue they care about can the
leader of the democratic party that's
President Biden can he drive drive those
voters to the poll okay I want to show
you a couple of things Vlad first of all
Joe Biden is a motivator but he's a
motivator for Republicans look at this
62 percent of Republicans saying that
he's a lot on their minds it's another
bite at the Apple they they lost in 2020
this is a chance to vote again typically
happens in a midterm but it's less so
for Democrats so that's part of trying
to motivate that base and here's another
part that I want to show you take a look
at the former president against the
current one wow he's driving voters too
Donald Trump he is just as much on
voters Minds as Joe Biden and it's a
positive for Republicans they think he's
fighting for them but for Democrats
they're out there to vote against him
wouldn't be surprised if Democrats in
this campaign keep talking about Donald
Trump all right Anthony salvanto always
great to have you on set man thank you
Nate back to you I love the way you
broke that down well done fellas